كيف تنتهي الحياه في لحظه كيف تبيد
الاشياء في ثوان بدا الفجر الكابوسي
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا مخبرا حيا للاسئله
الكبرى عندما ارتجت الارض وارتجفت اوصالها
لتفيق البشريه على جدران تهوي بالساكنين
وهم نيام فتقذف بهم من احلام الكره الى
فزع اليقظه وكان فزعا عظيما هرع الناس الى
الشوارع هائمين في البرد لا يدرون ما
يفعلونه ولا اين يذهبون يمر الوقت يزيد
عدد الضحايا وتختلط الجثث بصراخ المحتجزين
تحت الانقاض وتساؤلات القلق المميت عن
مفقود هنا وجريح هناك وقريب كان في منزل
صار قومه حجاره
والزلازل شبح صامت لكارثه متخفيه مباغته
صاعقه كان قدر اجزاء كبيره من تركيا ان
تكون على صدوعها الزلزال الاول بقوه سبعه
وسبعه اعشار درجه على مقياس ريختر وقع
قرابه الرابعه ونصف فجرا بتوقيت تركيا
وتبعته ارتدادات هي زلازل صغيره اسقطت ما
كان متصدعا من ابنيه ووسمت وجوه الناس
بالرعب وهم يدعون الى اللجوء لمناطق
مفتوحه تركز الزلزال في جنوب شرق تركيا
تحديدا في كهرمان مراش وشمل محافظات
ومناطق واسعه اهمها غازي عنتاب وديار بكر
واورفا وعثمانيه وملاطيا وعبر بقوه الى
سوريا فيما صداه الارضي يمتد مئات
الكيلومترات فشعر به سكان لبنان وقبرص
والعراق ودول اخرى اما شمال سوريا في
المناطق القريبه من الحدود التركيه خصوصا
في ادلب وحلب فكانت حصته موازيه للماساه
التركيه هنا في مدن القهر السوري الطويل
يعرف اهلها شكل الدمار وطعم الخوف لكنه
ياخذ كل مره طعمه المر الاول مباني سكنيه
مقتظه واحياء في مدن ضمت نازحين ومتعبين
ومعذبين سقطت وتدمرت وزاد في الماساه غياب
اجهزه انقاذ كافيه او خطه عمل لتوصيل
المساعدات واهمها الخيام والسعى صفه ثلجيه
لينتقل السوري الضحيه من خيمه الى خيمه
ومن ركام الى ركام ومن تهجير الى تهجير
لقد بدا زلزال تركيا المخيف هزه لعالم
افاق على مشهد الفناء فتسارعت الدول الى
عرض وتقديم المساعده وبلغ عددها بحسب
الرئيس التركي خمسا واربع الدوله فضلا عن
الامم المتحده وحلف النيتو لبرهه ظهرت
البشريه يدا واحده في وجه الكارثه فالتقت
اوكرانيا وروسيا في عرض العون ومثلها
الصين والولايات المتحده مشهد وليد الم
بخاطره امل اليس اجدر بالانسانيه ان
تتكاثف في وجه النوائب والمصائب وفي الكون
منها ما يكفي بدل ان تزيدها بالحروب
والصراعات وساحات القتل والسلاح
زلزال تركيا وسوريا وضع العالم كله امام
اختبار تامل في معنى الوجود وجدوى التناحر
والتباغض ان هي الا لحظه من يوم انهيار
الا ومضه من زمن فهل من متعظ